[موسيقى]
قد يبدو هذا وكأنه مجرد يوم آخر
في المكتب ، لكن بعض هؤلاء الرجال لديهم
خبرة في غسيل الأموال
والابتزاز وحتى الجرائم العنيفة ،
ولا توجد حاجة إلى أي من هذه المهارات في هذه
الوظيفة هؤلاء رجال العصابات السابقون من
وكالة التمثيل Takakura Gumi في انتظارهم
جديلة للاستعداد للعب دور أنفسهم السابقين
الذين عاشوا على الجانب الأيمن
من القانون
لا يعرفون طقوس الياكوزا أو
المافيا التي عشناها حقًا في ذلك العالم ،
كنا بلطجية محترفين ، يمكننا استخدام
ذلك لصالحنا
[موسيقى  ]
لا يزال لويجي بابا يرتدي
علامات المافيا التي تركها حياة جريمة
منذ ست سنوات ، ويجد غرضًا في التمثيل
أشعر وكأنني انتقلت من الجحيم إلى الجنة.
دفع الفواتير حتى يستمر
في وظيفته اليومية ، يدير بابا أعماله
التجارية الخاصة بالبرمجيات وهو أيضًا
من مستخدمي YouTube الناشئين بينما كنت بوبستر شعرت أنني لا أملك
السيطرة على مصيري الآن
أشعر وكأنني ولدت من جديد اليوم.
في مجموعة أفلام الحركة ، المقاتل المجنون
كالعادة ، يلعبون دور الأشرار مع
العادات المعروفة لأولئك الذين كانوا
في Yakuza
تعمل منظماتهم في سرية ، إنه عالم مظلم
مليء برموز الشرف غير المكتوبة
والتسلسلات الهرمية الصارمة التي يريدون مشاركتها  مع
جمهور أكبر ، يقول رئيس الوكالة
إن إعادة الاندماج في المجتمع
يشبه البدء من الصفر في
اليوم الثالث من ضحكة الكوكايين ، لكن جميعها
مهم حقًا بالنسبة لنا للمساهمة في
المجتمع والقبول به
وأعتقد أن صناعة الترفيه هي
أسرع طريقة بالنسبة لنا  قم
بالمهمة وهي بالتأكيد تحظى بقدر كبير من
الاهتمام في بلد
لا يزال فيه أفراد عصابات الياكوزا موصومين بوصمة عار ، ويريد رجال العصابات X هؤلاء
من العالم أن يعرف أن هناك
فداء حتى بالنسبة لأولئك الذين لديهم
ماضي أحلك ، إيفان واتسون.